uh I guess my stepdad's not Mall's dad
that's not prison forever he got out oh
no got arrested again my mom was surfing
the internet can I show you this man's
face now sure oh oh my God no no no see
his face
okay kind of almost brought a tear to my
how bad it is because I mean I love this
fool so this is a current Day picture
I've never seen right this is a current
picture now imagine this man in your
cell
with the [__] shiv
just rocked out like uh American History
X narrow Norton like he's a buff ass
fool look at him now and look how evil
now when you talk now that the stories
will make sense you're like that they
were scared of your stepdad like yeah
that full I know yeah I remember you sir
walked away remember all that [__] look
how [__] evil this guy looks now oh
my God oh my God
oh you got